la lame v agusta représente quelque
chose d'exceptionnel dans tout le
panorama du motocyclisme mondiale
c'est une histoire extraordinaire liée à
une période unique pendant laquelle de
grands champions et des moto très
performante qu'on tire 270 victoires
dans les grands prix du monde
il le fondateur de la société et le
conte giovanni agusta un pionnier de
l'aviation d'origine sicilienne qui
s'était installé dans l'italie du nord
mon
giovanni agusta fut un pionnier de
l'aviation
peu après le premier vol des frères
wright en 1907 il commencé à dessiner et
produire un biplan sans moteur qui se
souleva sur une vingtaine de mètres à
capoue elle c'est lui qui créé en 1923
la compagnie la crosstour johnny
aéronautique et agusta spa l'appui dont
le siège est le héros donne de cascina
costa dit ça m'a raté dans la province
de varese issihaka chine à khost il
commence à des travaux dans le secteur
de l'aéronautique en collaboration avec
les grandes entreprises de l'époque
marchetti caproni veedol et en
travaillant aussi pour l'aéronautique
italienne qui venait de naître
après sa mort survenue en 1927
l'entreprise pas ça dans les mains de sa
femme josé pinula et de son fils
domenico petit peu après dû affronter
une crise du secteur aéronautique
tellement grave qu'il lui fallut prendre
des mesures d'urgence et aux conjurés la
faillite
il eut l'idée de convertir la production
aéronautique en production de
motocyclettes surtout pour répondre au
désir que les italiens manifestait de
plus en plus de disposer d'une
indépendance pour leurs déplacements
thor à vienne où cela se fit grâce à la
ténacité et à la passion d'un homme
le conte domenico agusta
e
l'office chantée avec le bureau
technique commença à concevoir un moteur
2 temps de 80 18 centimètres cubes de
cylindrée destiné aux motocyclettes les
pères et les caractéristiques de ce
moteur devait répondre à un double enjeu
de faibles coûts de production et de
gestion le développement de ce moteur
subie un temps d'arrêt parce que le
deuxième conflit mondial s'intensifier
le développement ultérieur de la guerre
eu pour conséquence en 1943 l'occupation
d'origine de cascina costa par des
troupes allemandes en prévision de cette
catastrophe du 8 septembre 1943
tout le matériel déjà prêt les dessins
les machines et les outils furent cachés
par agusta hors de l'entreprise
les dessins furent confiés à un mario
rossi qui les gardent à chez lui les
machines furent cachés ici à cascina
costa par un employé de l'entreprise
mario jenna herti ce dernier est devenu
par la suite presque un symbole de la
maison de production où est assis toi tu
connais cette situation durera jusqu'à
la fin de la guerre quand domenico
agusta dans le but de faire aboutir son
projet de motocyclettes décida de fonder
la mécanique à verbier
il fit preuve d'une grande intuition
diversifier l'activité et se lancer dans
le domaine des transports dans une
italie qui était en train de renaître
des décombres de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est pourquoi avec guerra un
petit village proche du siège de son
entreprise il fonda en février 1945
la société anonyme mecanica vergara
débutant ainsi l'activité industrielle
le conte domenico agusta il ya très peu
d'exemples dans l'histoire italienne des
industries mécaniques d'une personnalité
aussi forte
le conte domenico agusta est
probablement le seul avec enzo ferrari a
laissé une empreinte personnelle d'une
telle importance est aussi durable à son
entreprise
le compte était assis dans son bureau à
cascina cost avec tous ces trophées
accroché au mur
c'était beaucoup mieux quand il était là
il ressemblait un peu à monsieur ferrari
il était très différent quand il était
au bureau
et quand il n'y était pas c'était très
difficile de le rencontrer et tout le
monde te rappeler constamment que
c'était lui le chef et qu'il était
toujours pressé je me rappelle d'une
fois en 1957
j'avais cherché à tout prix obtenir des
améliorations et un nouveau cadre pour
ma moto
finalement un rentrant du grand prix de
hollande
je décide est de rentrer en train et jeu
réservé une place dans le même train que
celui dans lequel voyageait le compte à
augusta pour avoir aussi du temps passé
avec lui une fois arrivé à milan
on avait décidé de construire un nouveau
cadre pour ma moto la soie aux corridas
s son autorité est tellement indiscuté
qu'elle ne laisse aucun espace à des
opinions différentes de la sienne
ses oeuvres sont toujours exécuté en
toute rigueur par ses techniciens qui
néanmoins reconnaissent en lui le chef
suprême
la référence on travaillait en suivant
directement les indications de domenico
agusta qui avaient des employés de
confiance dans les secteurs les plus
importants de l'entreprise
le conte leur donnait des orientations
et e rapporter directement à lui presque
tous les jours
gusta se rendait au bureau technique
environ deux fois par jour pendant les
périodes importantes pour l'entreprise
notamment les années 50 60
le contact était vraiment constants ont
réalisé un projet complet à partir des
premières lignes jusqu'à la production
en un an et parfois moins
willy des lacs et ça c'est un leader
sachant transmettre à ses employés une
passion grandissante pour les motos et
surtout pour les courses non qu'est
grâce aux résultats extraordinaires de
son équipe obtenue devant les
spectateurs du monde entier
un sentiment d'appartenance rend ces
hommes pierre leconte à augusta aimait
bien la victoire et le monde du
motocyclisme
mais nous aussi nous aimions la victoire
nous qui faisions tous ces sacrifices
pour la voir et c'est le compte serait
aussi faire des choix techniques de
grande envergure
l'attrait de la 3 cylindres courses par
exemple dont tout le monde se souvient
comme la moto la plus victorieuse mais à
partir d'une demande bien clair c'est
lui qui a proposé les trois cylindres et
moi j'avais en charge le projet en effet
j'ai passé deux ans sans partir en
déplacement
parce que j'étais en train de travailler
sur les 3 cl 1
franchement c'était vraiment un grand
moteur simple et puissant le conte en
était très fier
et de rappeler à l'écologie c'est donc
en reconnaissant les qualités du compte
que ses employés et ses collaborateurs
donner le maximum pour remporter la
victoire
le rapport avec à augusta était très
facile dans un certain sens mais
cependant exigeant parce qu'on devait
toujours gagner en effet quand on ne
gagnait pas on subissait des reproches
sévères
parfois le compte avait raison mais pas
toujours
on devait toujours cherché à gagner et
on a gagné plusieurs fois quand on
gagnait c'était normal quand on veut
gagner pas c'est tel drame
on ne compte pas les nuits passées à l'
usine
il est fait de passer au travail mais
cet homme exceptionnel récompensé
largement ces sacrifices avec une grande
générosité et les 270 victoires dans les
championnats du monde le démontre on
essayait les moteurs jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin parfois le compte arriver à cette
heure là pour nous contrôler il se
passionnait pour notre travail et ils
voulaient tout savoir en fait ont
travaillé toute la nuit il était
toujours là avec nous si c'était
nécessaire il arrivait avec des gâteaux
et à monza on a presque toujours gagner
j'ai été le chef du département course
chez ducati
j'avais vécu une séparation très
douloureuse
mais ici je suis très heureux
le conte domenico agusta sur la piste
non l'intérêt pour les courses n'était
pas qu'une façade
le conte domenico agusta nourrissait une
véritable passion pour les compétitions
moto ce qui le pousse à être toujours
présent au stand de ravitaillement pour
participer aux événements avec ses
pilotes et ses mécaniciens
le compte était présent à presque toutes
les compétitions
malgré tout le travail qu'il avait pour
diriger son entreprise de production
pour lui c'était un hobby il arrivait le
samedi et le dimanche soir ou bien le
lundi matin il était le premier à
rentrer la soie et en afrique c'était
une figure charismatique sous sa
direction tout le monde cherchait à
donner le meilleur de lui même
il est présenté ci le compte était
présentant aux épreuves du samedi qu aux
courses du dimanche et ne rate a aucun
rendez-vous heure de l'italie quand il
était au stand de ravitaillement et ils
chronométrait toujours personnellement
la vitesse véritable team manager d'un
autre temps manager
les courses
les organistes le début des compétitions
se fait en 1946 non non pas dans la
spécialité vitesse mais en régularité
à mon avis les compétitions de
régularité ont permis à mecanica vergara
de faire connaître sa marque sur tout le
territoire national
il s'agissait de plusieurs compétitions
par an dans toute l'italie en embauchant
un trio exceptionnel benzoni fornasari
event turin le compte à augusta a
commencé à gagner des compétitions
partout de 1946 à 1954
on compte 450 victoire
arrive alors et dès la première année on
remporte la victoire
il en résulta que la 98 de sport fut
mise en fabrication
c'est une moto avec une fourche
télescopique un cadre plus courts une
assiette plus basse et un moteur plus
puissant de comptes domenico agusta
était persuadé que les courses étaient
le moyen publicitaire le meilleur
surtout pour une marque jeune comme la
mv agusta les victoires dans les
compétitions de régularité ont fait
connaître au public la marque mv agusta
dans tout le pays
les victoires dans les compétitions de
vitesse ont fait commettre la marque
dans le monde entier
l'amendé boutonnet l'avait la moto du
début dans les courses de vitesse et la
mv agusta 125 à deux arbres de treize
chevaux à dix mille tours
la même année la route hier 500 4
cylindres est présenté au salon de milan
c'est une moto avec moteur à deux arbres
de 50 chevaux à partir de laquelle
l'ingénieur pieds trouvés morts
développe à la première 4 cylindres de
gp2 cascina cost
à
la manteau pour nom à cette moto après
de nombreuses modifications techniques
et confié à leslie g qui gagne en 1952
le grand prix de monza et de barcelone
c'est la chine si la 500 est compétitive
c'est la 125 à deux arbres conduite par
cécile sandford qui devient la moto à
battre grâce à la fin de la saison après
trois victoires
l'anglais devient champion du monde et
quoi c'est le premier titre mondial d'un
palmarès légendaire de 75 titres
arc-en-ciel 38 pilotes et 37
constructeur il remplace ou l'année
suivante le genou bialy déboule sur la
scène de la 125 arc en ciel avec cinq
victoires
il donne à l'écurie cascina costa le
premier de ses huit titres mondiaux
pendant que j'étais en train de démonter
ma moto je sens quelqu'un qui me tape
sur l'épaule
c'était domenico agusta il me dit ou
bien lui est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
voulez une de mes motos j'ai répondu ça
marche
j'ai laissé tomber ma moto et je me suis
consacré à la sienne à l'époque il y
avait une disposition différente du
groupe au départ des compétitions 20 à
la fois avec les meilleurs à la fin
beaucoup de gens à aller voir les
courses
au départ j'ai pris 100 150 mètres et
après 60 tours j'étais encore en 4e ou
5e position mais à 100 mètres du premier
groupe
je ne suis pas arrivé à les rattraper
parce que la moto était vraiment
différente par rapport à la mienne le
dimanche suivant à legnano ils m'ont
donné la moto officielle et j'ai gagné
ou bien lee était un très bon athlète
un technicien capable
il était très précis il savait faire des
travaux d'entretien sur sa moto
je parlais très peu généralement sur 27
10 échoué le niveau de la mécanique
était très haut et un dur travail
correspondait de bonnes prestations
quand le circuit était long je
m'arrêtais deux ou trois fois
je savais qu'en ralentir et quand poussé
la moto à fond et j'avais toujours le
meilleur chrono